[Music]
hey
it's us we're back again and we're back
we survived
yeah we're not even all that hungover no
that's a good show well like i said me
and tom are seasoned drinkers
so it's like it takes a lot more than
that to take us i can shake it off
easily
i am not seasoned but i got some food
and some water and i pushed right back
off like a wilted flower
and i had i didn't tell you but i think
i had two more drinks after we
finished the show because then you know
we went on and did some other [ __ ] yeah
we went on and did that other thing with
some creators they were all talking to
each other and i was [ __ ] trashed and
i'm [ __ ]
yelling and talking to the guys that i'd
recognized and didn't realize there were
40 other people yeah there was like 40
or 50 people in there what
it's like there's too many people yeah
and then they started talking
and it started to get like they were
actually like doing a show for each
other
talking about they were kind of drunk
paranormal [ __ ] now yeah they were all
we were like we gotta get out of here
well we were like really messed up too
like we were pretty drunk and yeah it
was getting late and i was kind of like
man i just kind of want to go to sleep
we didn't want to do another show
they all wanted to do a show for each
other
it's looking weird you know but yeah so
we decided today because we hadn't
watched any new new new movies
we decided that we were going to talk
about a 2014 movie that actually sophie
bought for us
and i had seen it before but tom hadn't
and this is called the voices now like i
said we reviewed one
called the voices from 2020. like a
while but it's a completely different
movie this is like a horror comedy
from ryan reynolds now what i'm gonna
say too that what we're what we just
decided to do like just five minutes ago
that we were talking about before we
started recording
was that for the matinee shows i feel
like i've been too
um focused on like getting like new
movies like from 2019 2020 and i feel
like i could expand that out
to like maybe a new movie would count as
like the last 10 years
because there's a lot of movies that i
would have liked to talk about but then
i was like oh it came out in 2017 or
2018. it's too
old you know for the matinee but too new
for the retrospective
so i feel like if we expanded the
matinee like out a little bit and then
we can just do that so i have like a
wider range of shapes you thank matt for
the 20.
uh yes i did but thank you very much
matt i typed it on there as well thank
you for the
yeah so yeah so because we had just
watched the voices
and um i was like well we didn't watch
have time to watch anything
newer than that so let's just talk about
that movie because we all really liked
that movie i've seen it twice
so if you've seen it a bunch of times
it's only the second time that's only
the second time you've seen it and tom
just saw it uh the first time
yeah i liked it it's good i like some
movie
sophie's got good taste in movies she
said you're gonna like this one watch
this one
yeah i did your voice i just did your
voice that's not really what she sounds
like though
that's like his generic that's what a
girl is
that's okay girls do that to you guys
i guess so but yeah so the interesting
thing about the second time that i
watched
the voices like just a couple nights ago
i didn't realize the first time that i
saw it that it was directed by
um marjan satrapi who is probably best
known for persepolis
like she did the uh the graphic novel
and uh then they did like an animated
film a bit later i think it was
nominated for an academy award like for
best animated feature like in 2008 or
something i want to say but yeah that
that graphic novel i read it
maybe a couple years after it came out
and it's excellent and like the um
the animated film is really good too so
i thought it was really cool i was like
holy [ __ ] i didn't realize that she had
directed this movie she doesn't direct a
[ __ ] son of movies but
she really liked this one a lot so the
premise of this movie
if you haven't seen it it might be on 2b
i forgot to check but i'm pretty sure it
might be on 2b if you want to watch it
for free
but um so there's a guy named jerry
played by ryan reynolds and he um
has some mental problems uh
chief among them is that his dog and his
cat talk to him
and um also he's maybe a serial killer
no he is a series
well yeah spoiler alert but yeah well i
mean it's not really a spoiler because
they kind of established that very at
the very beginning
what is kind of cool about this movie
it's i i would call this it's a horror
comedy i guess or a black comedy
um because it's fairly gory and uh you
know
but it's kind of like
he's you don't find out until later on
but i guess like there was something
with his mom and his mom had
i don't know if they're trying to say
that he had schizophrenia i guess it's
supposed to be
schizophrenia or something like that and
um
so he's been like on kind of an
outpatient program
so he has a job and everything i think
it's in some kind of factory
and um he's been on like
medication but he hasn't been taking the
medication because when he takes the
medication i guess he sees life as it
really is
and when he doesn't take the pressing
yeah and it's like when he doesn't take
it that's when the dog and cat talk to
him and that's when like he sees
everything like an idealized
version of everything yeah it's real
colorful and looking real happy
and [ __ ] his animals talk kind of
like a fake happy but he likes it he
enjoys
it yeah drugs wear off he realizes he's
in a shitty ass [ __ ] apartment
no it's the opposite if the drugs kick
that's what i meant that's right yeah
when he takes the drugs and the drugs
kick in he realizes he's in a shitty
apartment with dog [ __ ] everywhere and
just look at the yeah yeah there's like
boxes let's go forward yeah
the animals are trying to escape they're
not his friends you know it's looking
funny
yeah it's funny because the dog the
dog's name is bosco and then the cat's
name is mr whiskers
and the dog is essentially like the good
side of him
and then the cat is like his evil side
devil on your shoulder yeah
so it's like basically the cat is just
telling you know it's okay to kill
people it's like that's the only way you
feel alive and stuff like that
another thing that i didn't know about
this movie until we watched the making
of [ __ ]
was that ryan reynolds did the voice for
the dog
and the voice for the cat which i
thought was really crazy because the cat
has like a scottish accent it was a
scottish or iron or
north of england or some kind of accent
like that and it was really well done so
i thought
i didn't realize that that he had done
all three of those voices
which i guess it shouldn't surprise me
that much because he does do like a lot
of
voice work and [ __ ] like that but i mean
the [ __ ] that the cat says is like super
funny
but yeah so he gets he basically gets a
crush on this
hot english chick uh that works at his
job who's actually played by gemma
arderton she was in gemma somewhere
quantum of solace right yeah
yeah i think so yeah i think it was
continuous she was she played uh
that one one of the uh yeah somebody
from the embassy
didn't she play some girl from the
embassy yeah because we knew she got
tied up with her
yeah because i was like man i know i've
seen that chick before like her voice
was very familiar and his face was very
familiar but i'm pretty sure she was in
quantum masalas among other things
but so um her name is fiona right the
character name
in this movie not in the not in quantum
cells but yeah so he kind of gets a
crush on her asks her out she doesn't
really have anything to do with it but
she's kind of
too nice to like blow him up like saying
no [ __ ] off
so she kind of like yeah i'll go out on
a date with you whatever just like leave
me alone and then like he
then she kind of stands him up and then
it
happens that well you're not really sure
if this is how it happens
because you can't really trust anything
in the movie because you can't really
trust anything because he's not
perceiving things the way they really
are
like i thought it was cool like the
first time i watched the movie and
you're watching it the whole time like
he has this really nice apartment like
you know the dog and cat are talking and
everything seems fine like he seems like
super happy
but then like when he takes the pills
and he wakes up when it and he's in what
his apartment really looks like
and it's just like this horrible
[ __ ] yeah and i really really liked
that
uh that aspect of the movie yeah
visually the the whole
um rose-colored glasses uh kind of
element of the movie kind of reminded me
remember that movie about the romantic
comedies but little fat girl isn't it
romantic isn't it romantic yeah that
came out
she liked that movie i did too i thought
it was like really entertaining and she
she was living
in her own romantic fantasy like a
romantic comedy fantasy
although she hated it she hated it she
well she woke up
she didn't want it she just woke up one
day but visually the way
her romantic fantasy yeah looked a lot
like his
like his yeah his uh romantic fantasy i
guess that's what it is
because it was his version of reality
was just a movie that was running
through his head you were able to see it
yeah you know until he took those pills
and it would go away
and he didn't want that yeah cause
everything looked really
shitty and bad like it looked like like
i said there was dog poop all over his
apartment there was body parts and blood
everywhere from where he had like
killed people doing stupid [ __ ] keeping
heads in the fridge
yeah but when he when he didn't take the
pills like the heads talk to him and
like gave him ideas and stuff
yeah it's when we were watching the
behind the scenes
the guy i think the guy that wrote it he
said he got the idea
from he's like i was watching a
documentary or some like expert on
serial killers or whatever
and he's like this guy was saying that
all serial killers
have you know the easiest way to catch
them is to figure out
what the movie is that's playing in
their head
and the writer of this movie said i want
to see that movie so he decided to write
a movie about
a serial killer and what was going on in
their head and how it might have been
it's good because it's funny and it's
gory and [ __ ]
but you still feel bad for him even
though he does terrible things because
he's sick he can't help it he's a serial
killer kind of like jeffrey dahmer
yeah and temperament he's kind of like
jeffrey dahmer
you know and i don't know how much you
want to give away about his name said
about his mom
you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah like
he had a bad childhood he has a genetic
component
for this mental illness and then
yeah this the stuff with his mom because
remember how
how she passed away yeah was kind of
traumatic for him
yeah he got in trouble so it was kind of
it kind of put him on a bad path
yeah he's not like uh um he's not like
sexually sadistic or anything
as far as you can tell he's he's he's
one of those emotional [ __ ]
like
like dom are trying to keep people as
friends he wants friends
it's good movie though i liked it i
liked it yeah i did as well it's i
really like
things that are you know this kind of
tone that are like
a horror like a horror movie but funny i
don't know if i'd call this a horror
comedy as much as i call it like a black
comedy because i don't know it's really
a horror movie even though instead of a
serial killer
and there is like some gore in it um you
know like
heads getting severed and deers crashing
through windshields and
well you think that's what happened it's
hard to tell what exactly happened
because he was tripping at that time
that's what i mean like natural he may
have run her over
yeah that's true okay
yeah i mean there's no way yeah really
no once you finish the movie you realize
that you're not really sure
like if you saw what actually happened
or not like did he really not mean to
kill that girl was it just kind of like
an axe because it kind of looked like an
accident
i think but he might have been like
justifying it to himself like oh you
know i was just
i was trying to help her that she didn't
like him because
she set him up so she was like he was
like oh [ __ ] if
this is my only chance she doesn't
actually like me so if i want to be with
her
i got to make my move so i can keep her
forever
yeah yeah it might have been that i
don't think any of it was an accident
yeah see i don't think so either and and
it's just town himself it was an
accident yeah
it seemed like to yeah it seemed like
too that i think at that point like the
first
murder that we know of that he committed
um
was even though he like made it seem
like an accident in his own mind
but i think that what happened was even
if the first
like wound or whatever had been an
accident i think they were tying it back
to what happened with his mom
and him like his perception of it being
like oh well now i have to put them out
of their
misery yeah because i hurt because i
hurt them yeah
you know i didn't want to get in trouble
either yeah but he didn't really know
he didn't really know what was going on
because it's like you know after he
killed the first one it's like he took
the body but then he left like a bunch
of guts and a shoe and everything like
that so he didn't
he didn't really know i don't think he
even took the body at first the cat told
him
that's right yeah because the body was
still there like you got to go bury the
body you got to do something about that
yeah and so then it kind of set them
rolling on a course yeah because that
was i really liked the whole cat dog
dynamic i mean the cat in this was
hilarious him you gotta go to the police
you gotta clear your conscience go take
care of it and the cat's like are you
crazy
you're gonna get locked away forever
that's not what you do yeah yeah so the
cat was like giving him because like i
said they were
you know like you said it was like an
angel and devil on their shoulder like
you know his his conscience like two
side of it and they were always
fighting but it's like the funny thing
about the dog too is that he kept
telling him that he was a good boy
until by the end remember he's like i
think i reevaluated
boy you're a good yeah i don't know
it's just yeah it's like it's a really
really delightful movie if you're into
that kind of thing
like i said i think it's on tubey or it
was i don't know if it's still on there
anymore
i think i saw it on there like a while
back when i was looking
about that other movie the voices i
think that one came up as well
so if you are interested in seeing it
like i said it came out in 2014
and uh you know now that we've expanded
the years out for them
thank you mango a belated birthday
flashball
thank you i did which didn't was mango
here last night
i think it was yeah i don't know yeah i
was going to say i can't remember like
because there was so many
quest because i was like did you you
might come a little bit later yeah maybe
that's what it was
yeah cause i was like i was gonna say oh
did you see like mirror
you know mirror universe bach and baby
yoda back there
and the shining board game and
everything another thing this kind of
reminded me of is that this movie kind
of reminded me a little bit of dexter
yeah it was like very similar theme to
that and i think dexter you'd like this
and i think like i saw another review
like a professional critic reviewing
likes
that um also compared it yeah to that
was this is it's similar kind of like
maybe a little bit funnier
all right but it's not look it's not a
funny topic what it is the dude's
hallucinations are funny
yeah you're seeing his hallucinations
but he's a serial killer yeah
and i don't think it's an accident he
doesn't really want to do it he just has
to do it
because it's in him yeah that's what i
think is going on and i mean the cat is
the best part
mr whiskers and i love the voice for him
and i love it even more now that i know
that ryan
did that the cat's trying to justify it
he's like look man you know i kill [ __ ]
i never i love to kill [ __ ] yeah and and
it
is it's just like that you know the
dog's going no hold on
that's not who you are yeah right yeah
don't listen to him
and he doesn't jerry he knows he even
says it in therapy
or maybe not in therapy but he says like
to the cat and the dog like i know you
guys aren't real like i know you're just
me
so who am i listening to because you're
just extensions of me
so it's like who am i then because i
have the good side the bad side and then
who
what you know like you got three parts
of yourself yeah and the girls are
the dead girls are talking to him too
yeah once he starts murdering all the
heads are in the fridge and they're yeah
and they're all talking to him you know
they're all like idealized girlfriends
and [ __ ] you know
and then they're friends with each other
and it's it's just
[Laughter]
it's [ __ ] it's funny when you look at
it that way
but it's not funny when you realize that
all those crazy [ __ ] are doing
that
well yeah what's in their mind and
that's what the movie was supposed to be
that yeah that's what the guy that wrote
it that's who said that's where he got
the idea it was like i want to see the
movie that's going on inside of serious
killers
some of the some of these serial killers
essentially see themselves as good
people
this is just something most people see
themselves this is just something beyond
their control
and they're gonna try to deal with it
and i think dahmer actually thought he
was a good person
uh he wasn't though and i think yeah
when
you know when we talked about jeffrey
dahmer he is i i don't generally feel
sorry for serial killers
i do feel a little bit sorry for him
yeah
because he really didn't seem i mean
because there's some serial killers that
are just they know
that he's just a needy [ __ ] yeah
well
the the probably like the most ted bundy
was the one that really was probably the
most dangerous
yeah and not only did he think he was a
good person he thought he was an
awesome [ __ ] he thought he was
awesome yeah great
that women were bad and that they
deserved what was happening to them
basically that's
that's what you're dealing with yeah
yeah and i mean they do have some kind
of self-awareness but i think they're
you know when you get into like
sociopaths that think they're like
that are so arrogant they think they're
just better than everybody so they you
know have the right
yeah yeah to do that kind of stuff yeah
where i i'm not sure if dahmer had that
you know what i mean i didn't think he
said he had that same i'm not saying
emotionally needy
that's what i mean and he he was just
like warped she's kind of a parasite
you know so i don't know if he was
necessarily sociopathic
in the same sense as somebody like ted
bundy was i think he was just
psychopathic maybe
it's hard to say although i mean no he
yeah there was there was some mental
[ __ ] going on they can talk themselves
into stuff
like a normal person would do you can
come up with justifications for it yeah
because i do feel like that's a very
human thing not just among serial
killers but
you know you kind of just do what you
want to do and then you justify it
conor had a bunch of abandonment issues
he thought eaton's eating these dudes
was gonna keep them with him
yeah and uh he didn't want he was trying
to make them
living sex dolls out of little filipino
boys or whatever it was
he's like injecting yes so if you
actually look at what they're doing the
shit's [ __ ] nasty
you know what i mean his intent doesn't
matter at that point he's well doesn't
that dude [ __ ] lost the ability to
[ __ ]
be able you know i mean he's lost the
ability to [ __ ]
function in society i mean that's yeah
that's what i was going to say was that
even though you know i i find it
interesting like the different
motivations and the different reasons
that they do these types of things
um you know and some some of the [ __ ]
can be helped and some of it not
but in the end the result is the same
yeah he was
actually i'm saying he couldn't function
in society that [ __ ] couldn't function
in prison either you can't do that in
prison
they'll kill you and they did yeah you
know he just couldn't function in the
world
yeah once you get that bad you're you're
through
you gotta go yeah that's um that's a
line that once you've crossed yeah
it's kind of you gotta go back after
that you can't you can't be hanging
around
after you've done some [ __ ] like that
yeah rip really just you've done that
one time and it was like nope
injecting drainage puts you over here
into people's brains and turn them into
a sex zombie
so they don't leave you you gotta go
it's like i don't think there's any
fixing this that's it you know what i
mean that's terrible
all right one of my favorite things too
about this movie which i think i
remember
is when jerry how he justifies it too
because the therapist
asks them do you hear disembodied voices
and he thinks about it and he's like
no because all the voices he hears have
to have like a face and a like if to be
an animal or a human head or something
like that so
yeah no they're just talking to me like
i'm having a regular conversation
so he's like that's not a crate it's not
a crazy person thing right
like because they're all they have
bodies they're not just bodies
they're coming from somewhere like they
can't be that bad it's not
that's not crazy that's kind of a funny
way to justify it
right yeah and that's exactly right like
all of the voices
right had a source so it's like he
didn't see it as but he did have some
self-awareness in the sense that he knew
that the cat and dog weren't really
talking to him
you know what i mean sort of he sort of
seemed to have some kind of
self-awareness about it
fourth drawer down says mirror spock
approves this movie
he does i don't know if he would though
because there's a lot of irrationality
well he would say it was this it was a
study
in human irrationality it perfectly
it perfectly example exemplifies humans
yeah
that's a good the worst of humanity yeah
that's exactly what he would say
mary universe spock and regular spock
yeah i feel like didn't have a lot of
not as many differences maybe it's a
different situation
yeah situationally they were different
he still he still
seemed yeah like a like a kind of okay
dude
so in in expanded universe of star trek
in the mirror universe
uh spock became he got he kind of tried
to reform the terran empire and make it
into something good for a while
yeah it didn't ultimately work but
but he tried again i tried yeah i don't
know the whole story i don't remember it
actually yeah it's been a long time
since i've heard what happened to him i
think he got assassinated eventually if
i remember correctly so
somebody might be able to uh uh clear
that up but i think he eventually got
assassinated yeah i'm sure somebody out
there knows
yeah all right uh okay so
that'll do it for our matinee today
we'll be back with another one tomorrow
uh we don't know what movie it'll be
it'll be a surprise for all of us
uh so thanks for dropping by thanks for
watching and we'll see you tomorrow
bye